These were the missing signs and numbers for the perfect square trinomial
patterns. Great work if you got all four of these correct. We know the first
one needs to be positive 9, because this middle term is positive 18x. When we
have the quantity a plus b squared, we know we'll get a squared plus 2ab plus b
squared. So, this middle term is 2 times the multiplication of these two terms.
Since we already have an x here, we know that we just need two times this
number. So this number would have to be 9. We use similar reasoning to figure
out the other three problems, and we just need to pay attention to what sign
this is. This sign will indicate what sign we use in the parentheses. If it's a
minus, we'll use minus. If it's a plus, we'll use plus.